migrants at a bus station in monterrey
mexico it's a large crowd and it's
growing so is the frustration
though mexico's government recently
granted special transit visas to
migrants which allow them to travel
freely anywhere in the country many say
federal and state police have been
illegally returning them to monterrey
with no regard for their health or
safety
we are not criminals we are human beings
no human being on this planet is illegal
please let us go on our way
migrants say authorities are also giving
them false information this video
obtained by al jazeera appears to show a
mexican police officer telling
passengers aboard a bus that their visas
are not valid
you cannot travel toward a border that's
the first point that's why we're here
because the united states it's it's
politics because the government
complains to mexico because we're
allowing access through the borders
mexican immigration authorities declined
our request for an on-camera comment
but told al jazeera the conduct of
mexican officers in the recorded video
would be examined
another video this one recorded in
guatemala appears to show a police
officer holding cash in his hands and
asking passengers for money
roberto a migrant from venezuela who
gave us the footage has asked us not to
reveal his identity
he says shakedowns by corrupt police
along the entire migrant route are
commonplace
i said to the officer please i can't
give you the money i don't have it he
said i'm not interested give me the
money or find another border
we shared roberto's video with
authorities in guatemala and received
the following response
the inspector general of the national
civil police has launched an
investigation to hold these two police
officers responsible
they can clearly be seen in a video
receiving an amount of money
migrants who travel across mexico on
their way to the united states face many
threats including extortion robbery and
kidnapping
human rights activists in mexico have
called on mexican officials as well as
on criminal cartels who operate along
mexico's northern border to respect the
rights of migrants as they transit the
country
manuel rapalo al jazeera